this is Startalk I'm gonna start off
with one that I like a lot from Mike
Dotson comes to us from Earth and
Facebook okay because we agreed if they
don't say where they're from
you're gonna say they're from Earth
they're from garden so people start
telling me where you're from when you
send these in please all right here we
go
if there was a superhero whose power was
to see the whole spectrum of light what
do you think he or she would see and
what could we learn from him or her so
that first of all this this person
doesn't exist in superhero land so
that's what's I think is cool about this
but what if your power was to see all
the spectrum of light at once such a
person has already been created in the
world of science fiction Wow
it's Jordy Stark that is correct sir
because he is absolutely blind but he
uses his visor to see all the different
spectrums of light correct he has full
wide spectrum vision of the world yes
and it was quite a discovery in
astrophysics that there's more to the
universe than just visible light
detectable by your retina it was it was
I count it as one of the great demotions
of human physiology where you learned
that this cherished sense that we have
called sight right is actually quite
feeble relative to all the things that
are seeable out there in this world so
we're not seeing any we ain't seen Jack
and in fact you you are familiar with
the other parts of the electromagnetic
spectrum whether or not you knew that
that's what they were so ultraviolent
right x-rays right gamma gamma rays
infrared microwaves radio waves all of
this including visible light are part of
a continuum of electromagnetic energy
Wow and so if you could see all of that
it would be a really visually noisy
world okay because if I'm looking at you
now you'd be glowing with infrared at
your 98.6 degrees right I'd look at your
cellphone it would be glowing with with
microwaves right if by the way if you
could see all spectrum if you're driving
the car you'd be able to see the police
the
police radar gun great mala wooden at
you from right right you say up let me
slow down I got you right and even if he
had a laser radar gun you'd be able to
say you'll be sure no matter the
frequency of light right so so it would
be be immensely empowered to know what's
going on in this world
sweet yeah yeah yeah now that's kind of
like predator right but Heath no he only
was able to see it's infrared predator
saw infrared right considered the
predator of the film plus in that movie
so we had infrared scopes in the day
right and what you saw in the infrared
scopes is what it looked like to him
right okay however the infrared scopes
are like low resolution right you just
see these blogs and blobs of moving
right right just these or more fists
kind of blobs right if he's an alien
that had advanced technology he'd be
able to see infrared with as much detail
as you see visible light Wow
why not exactly he'd be able to see like
the the hands are a little cool slightly
cooler than the rest of the body
because it's an extremity he'd be able
to see all these details but the best we
can think of doing is give him the damn
low resolution infrared scopes and just
see a bunch of blobs let's see a bunch
of blobs moving around Bay so he had
infrared site and but it's not clear
that he could see in other wavelengths
that wasn't obvious so that's actually a
very cool superhero to be able to see in
every spectrum yeah I'll let you won't
see but then for me a hero has to do
something about you got you got to do
something yeah have very low
expectations for my heroes you like the
data taking exactly my superhero just
shows up and tells me stuff like his
power is that's hot don't tough it this
is Startalk